mes chers collègues notre commission
d'enquête sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française poursuit
aujourd'hui ces travaux avec sa seconde
audition de l'après-midi en recevant des
acteurs de la distribution
pharmaceutique maillon incontournable de
la chaîne d'approvisionnement médicament
des plus de 21000 officines françaises
mais aussi plus minoritairement de nos
hôpitaux
il nous a en effet paru important de
tenter d'y voir clair dans le circuit de
distribution des médicaments qui ne
bride pas en France par sa simplicité du
site de production à la pharmacie les
flux médicaments sont en effet gérés
selon diverses modalités les grossistes
répartiteurs premièrement sont des
établissements pharmaceutiques et ont
des obligations de services publics ils
doivent des servir toutes les officines
de leur secteur livré tout médicament de
leur stock dans les 24 heures et détenir
en permanence 90% des présentations de
spécialités pharmaceutiques
commercialisées en France ainsi qu'un
stock représentant 15 jours de
consommation habituelle sur leur zone de
chalandise déclarées laquelle est
soumise à autorisation du directeur
général de la NSM
deuxième type d'acteurs les dépositaires
ils ne sont pas propriétaires des
médicaments dont ils assurent la
distribution en tant que prestataire de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ils agissent
au nom de et pour le compte d'un donneur
d'ordre dont il sont les sous-traitants
leur mode de rémunération donc leur
équilibre économique diffère à cet égard
de celui des grossistes répartiteurs
dont le modèle repose sur une marge
réglementée fixée par les pouvoirs
publics
troisième possibilité certains
laboratoires vendent leurs produits
directement aux officines notamment mais
pas seulement lorsqu'il s'agit de
médicaments onéreux ou quand la
population concernée est faible
à propos de cette relation directe entre
laboratoire et pharmaciens le président
l'Union des syndicats de pharmaciens
d'officine nous a parlé de pratiques
commerciales
entre guillemets puisque c'est une
citation douteuse se court-circuitage
dégrossistes procédant paradoxalement
d'un circuit plus long et plus complexe
moins transparent pour le pharmacien et
d'une dégradation de la qualité de la
provisionnement vous nous direz ce que
vous pensez de ces appréciations la
difficulté provient à la fois de cette
coexistence de divers types de flux et
du non-respect des obligations de
service public pour certains grossistes
dit shortliners qui porte atteinte à
l'image de la profession ceci loin de
détenir la collection requise acquiert
des stocks pour un assortiment très
limité de spécialités et les revendent à
d'autres distributeurs notamment au sein
de l'Union européenne créant de fait une
concurrence entre les pays il joue ainsi
du différentiel de prix entre le marché
français et les marchés étrangers et ce
phénomène d'export parallèle est souvent
cité parmi les facteurs de pénurie un
des facteurs les dépositaires et les
short liners sont souvent pointés du
doigt en ce qu'il contribuerait à la
déstabilisation du marché du médicament
vous nous direz si c'est légitime
afin de commencer de tirer tout cela au
clair et en attendant d'auditionner la
chambre syndicale de la répartition
informatique qui représente les
grossistes répartiteurs d'envergure
nationale nous recevons aujourd'hui
monsieur Anthony pusot secrétaire
général et Antoine pezzo président de la
Fédération Française de la distribution
pharmaceutique la FFDP qui est
l'organisation représentative des
grossistes répartiteurs régionaux et
indépendants représentant donc les
opérateurs de proximité de la
répartition car l'enjeu du maillage
territorial en matière de distribution
du médicament et de lutte contre les
pénuries étaient évidemment essentiel il
s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans l'enjeu du
maillage territorial de l'accès à la
santé et à la bonne prise en charge
sanitaire nous recevons également
Monsieur Frédéric de Girard
vice-président de la Fédération
nationale des dépositaires
pharmaceutiques plus connu sous le nom
de lock santé qui est accompagné de
monsieur Germain hazard secrétaire
général
la profession de dépositaire est en
moins connue que celle de grossiste
répartiteurs son rôle étant peut-être
moins clairement défini et soulevant
davantage interrogations il importait
que nous vous donnions la parole je vais
vous citer à chacun tour à tour la
parole pour un bref propos introductif
et quand je dis bref c'est bref qui vous
donnera l'occasion de nous éclairer très
concrètement sur vos métiers respectifs
et de nous présenter vos analyses et
préconisations concernant la prévention
et la gestion des pénuries de
médicaments vous pourrez compléter
ensuite en répondant aux questions de
Madame la rapporteur et de nos collègues
madame Laurence Cohen non Cohen donc
rapporteur de notre commission vous
posera une série première série de
questions et je précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite chacun à votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieur Anthony Puzzo
je suis Antoine Puzzo monsieur de Girard
ainsi que Monsieur esard
je vous remercie et je vais donc
maintenant vous donner successivement la
parole vous voudrez bien le cas échéant
indiquer quelles sont vos éventuelles
liens d'intérêt je vais commencer par
Monsieur plus de
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente madame le rapporteur Madame
et Monsieur les sénateurs je vous
remercie de permettre à la Fédération
Française de la distribution
pharmaceutique d'être auditionnée dans
le cadre de cette commission d'enquête
sur les pénuries de médicaments mais si
vous le permettez je vais présenter en
quelques mots notre fédération la
Fédération Française de la distribution
pharmaceutique a été fondée le 12
février 2017 par le souhait de grossiste
répartiteur régionaux et indépendant
soucieux de leur mission de santé
publique pour être une force de
proposition auprès des instances
régaliennes et des structures
représentatives du monde pharmaceutique
nous nous définissons en tant que
régionaux par le fait que nous exercions
notre activité sera un territoire de
répartition correspondant le plus
souvent à quelques départements ou à une
région
cette localisation sur nos territoires
implique une bonne connaissance de nos
activités de nos zones d'activités
pardon en termes de maillage
pharmaceutique de patients et de
population la proximité que nous
entretenons avec les pharmaciens
d'officine nous permet d'avoir la
connaissance de leurs problématiques en
outre nous n'avons aucune ambition
nationale
également nous sommes indépendants
financièrement de toute structure au
groupe d'entreprises ce qui nous confère
une grande liberté d'action et de
décision
le sujet de la pénurie est un sujet
auquel nous sommes confrontés tous les
jours dans notre pratique quotidienne le
grossiste répartiteur et le pivot
essentiel de la chaîne du médicament en
tant que lien entre les laboratoires et
les officines par sa position entre ces
deux maillons de la chaîne il subit à la
fois les problématiques de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et celles des pharmacies
d'officine
notre activité est sous tendue par des
référentiels notamment le Code de Santé
publique et les bonnes pratiques de
distribution en gros nous conférons une
responsabilité qui se manifeste par nos
obligations de services définies par ces
mêmes textes alors ces obligations sont
vous les avez rappelé tout à l'heure
madame la Présidente de livrer en moins
de 24 heures tout officines faisant une
demande dans la limite de notre
territoire de répartition de disposer de
15 jours de stocks de disposer des 9
dixièmes des spécialités pharmaceutiques
commercialisées en France et effectuer
des astreintes conjointement avec nos
confrères
en septembre 2021 la vigilance vis-à-vis
des médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs appelés aussi et mitem a été
ajouté
aujourd'hui la réalisation de ces
obligations est impactée par les
pénuries de médicaments qui se
matérialise pour les grossistes
répartiteurs régionaux de manière
différente de manière
en premier lieu les difficultés
d'approvisionnement en médicaments
auprès des laboratoires en termes de
profondeur tout autant que de largeur de
par la définition juridique le grossiste
répartiteur ne produit pas il ne peut
que distribuer en l'état un médicament
acquis auprès d'un exploitant pour le
distribuer dans les mêmes conditions à
l'officine qui en fait la demande
en d'autres termes si je ne suis pas
livré je ne peux donc pas distribuer aux
officines malgré le fait d'avoir
commandé le 10 médicaments
j'ajouterai que nous n'accédons pas
toujours à la totalité des gammes des
laboratoires qu'on appelle communément
la largeur et que nous ne recevons
toujours pas la quantité de montée ce
qu'on appelle aussi la profondeur
ce dernier cas implique la notion de
quota ou produit contingenté de plus en
plus drastiques sur un nombre croissant
de médicaments
lorsqu'un produit est contagenté nous
disposons uniquement d'une quantité
limitée octroyée par le laboratoire sur
la base de nos parts de marché calculer
à l'échelon national cependant cette
quantité contingentée ne couvre pas la
totalité des demandes des pharmacies que
nous livrons
nous avons aussi constaté un allongement
aléatoire des délais de livraison de
certains laboratoires augmentant ainsi
la complexité de gestion des stocks
également nous rencontrons des
difficultés à conclure des conventions
avec des laboratoires de générique pour
disposer de leur gamme nous limitant
ainsi l'accès à des alternatives
thérapeutiques pour une même molécule à
des prix compétitifs
à ce titre et selon l'article
l5121-29 du Code de Santé publique les
grossistes répartiteurs doivent être
approvisionnés de manière continue et
appropriée afin de leur permettre de
remplir leur obligation de service
public
comme dit prédécemment près décemment
précédemment nous sommes en lien étroit
avec les pharmaciens d'officine qui nous
font part de leur désarroi et de leurs
difficultés à trouver les médicaments
pour leur patient tout autant que du
temps considérable passer à le chercher
il est d'autant plus difficile pour nous
grossiste répartiteur de répondre par la
négative lorsque ces pharmaciens
s'adressent à nous en espérant obtenir
le médicament considéré
difficulté accrues par le fait de lui
expliquer que nous n'avons pas été
livrés ou que le quota reçu des
laboratoires ne couvre pas les demandes
des officines
dans la plupart des cas nous sommes
également dans l'impossibilité de
fournir une date prévisionnelle de
réapprovisionnement car celle-ci n'est
pas renseignée dans le DP rupture malgré
cela nous essayons tant bien que mal de
dialoguer avec les laboratoires afin
qu'ils débloque les quantités
nécessaires sur preuve de demande
officinale mais sans aucun succès dans
la plupart des cas
sur un plan économique l'abaissement des
prix des médicaments au cours des années
à diminuer notre marge notre
rémunération ne repose que sur la
différence entre le prix de vente et le
prix d'achat autrement dit la marge
celle-ci à l'heure actuelle est de 6 93%
mathématiquement la diminution du prix
fabricant engendre une baisse de
celle-ci en valeur absolue alors qu'en
parallèle les frais d'exploitation et de
transport augmentent
voilà succinctement les difficultés
rencontrées par les grossistes
répartiteurs face aux pénuries de
médicaments
même si le sujet est multifactoriel
quelques éléments pourraient contribuer
à l'atténuer en ce qui concerne les
grossistes répartis de régionaux et
indépendants
le plus grossiste répartiteur de par sa
position dans la Chine du médicament
constitue le lien dispensable entre les
exploitants et les officines de
pharmacie par pour la couverture
médicamenteuse d'un territoire donné
donc à l'accès aux médicaments par la
population
lorsque le pharmacien d'officine passe
par les stocks d'urgence pour obtenir le
médicament concerné les délais de
livraison sont augmentés alors qu'il
serait réduit par les grossistes
répartiteurs qui sont à même de gérer
l'urgence
dans un souci déficience de la
couverture médicamenteuse d'un
territoire sanitaire des stocks
d'urgence devrait être présents au sein
des grossistes répartiteurs régionaux la
mise à disposition dans ces structures
de proximité
garantiraient un accès rapide à ce type
de médicaments aux officines et par
extension aux patients
en outre cette gestion de stock
d'urgence via les grossistes
répartiteurs permettrait d'alléger les
frais de stockage supporté par les
exploitants
ces stocks d'urgence seraient constitués
à partir des stocks de sécurité des
exploitants sur la base des parts de
marché Gers respectives de chaque
grossiste ces stocks doivent être gérés
en région à l'instant de la demande de
l'officine et non pas à partir d'une
plateforme nationale rajoutant un délai
supplémentaire de livraison
cette gestion des stocks d'urgence
implique une transparence vis-à-vis des
autorités sanitaires régionales
notamment les ARS notamment par la
production des documents de vente et
d'achat afin de justifier les flux de
produits je vais déjà ce que nous
faisons dans la gestion du paxlovide
avec santé publique France
les auditions précédentes ont mis en
avant la notion d'anticipation des
pénuries notion que nous mettons déjà en
application notamment en adaptant nos
rythmes de commande auprès des
laboratoires lorsque là est possible
même si cela ne dure qu'un temps
également lorsque nous connaissons la
date de réapprovisionnement du
médicament communiqué par le laboratoire
vers le DP rupture nous faisons de même
cependant force est de constater que ces
dates sont très peu renseignées sur
cette plateforme
dans cette même idée il n'est pas rare
que le pharmacien de l'officine nous
pose la question de cette fameuse date
afin de pouvoir lui-même anticiper
information que nous sommes dans
l'impossibilité de lui donner
il devient aujourd'hui nécessaire que
les informations de réapprovisionnement
soient renseignées dans le déperuptures
afin de pouvoir anticiper la gestion des
stocks des médicaments en pénurie tout
en informant les officines
mais si vous le permettez je vais
attirer votre attention sur des aspects
plus économiques en lien avec la pénurie
nos établissements pharmaceutiques sont
des entreprises en pleine croissance et
cela malgré les difficultés évoquées
cependant elles sont assujetties au
paiement de la taxe sur la vente en gros
plus communément appelé la taxe acosse
calculer sur le chiffre d'affaires et
son évolution entre l'année N et l'année
n-1
cette taxe comporte trois parts dans la
première représente 1,75% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'année N cette première
part a fait l'objet de nombreux
amendements pour abaisser son taux de
contribution lors des différents projets
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale présentée annuellement ces
amendements ont été à chaque fois
rejetés
la deuxième part est basée sur le
différentiel entre le chiffre d'affaires
en année N et celui réalisé en année N-1
cette tranche est en taxée hauteur de
2,25%, ce différentiel peut être négatif
ou positif si cette seconde part est
positive elle est ton mat type
pratiquement ajoutée à la part 1 même si
mais si elle est négative elle est
soustraite à cette première part à
Besson à sa contribution
la thématique c'est la pénurie de
médicaments
[Musique]
cette deuxième part engendre un impact
préjudiciable important directement sur
les grossistes répartiteurs régionaux et
indépendants vis-à-vis de leur
croissance en d'autres termes plus de
nos entreprises grandissent par
l'augmentation de leur chiffre d'affrets
de leur chiffre d'affaires plus la
contribution est importante
les établissements pharmaceutiques
grossistent au répartiteur régionaux
indépendant grandissent augmente leur
masse salariale tout en participant la
dynamique économique locale
taux de croissance nécessite logiquement
une augmentation de ressources humaines
tout autant que financière pour garantir
leur développement afin d'assurer leur
mission de service public dans l'intérêt
des officines et par extension des
patients lorsque la part 2 négative
notre fédération a proposé de la
maintenir dans le calcul du montant de
la contribution à l'inverse lorsque la
part demeure positive nous avons proposé
de réaffecter son menton dans le
financement de la formation des équipes
et les recrutements de nouveaux
collaborateurs j'insiste je voudrais
vraiment comprendre la logique avec la
pénurie de médicaments s'il vous plaît
monsieur alors je vais la conclure
dessus si vous le permettez merci
beaucoup la pénurie de médicaments ne
couvre pas uniquement la disponibilité
des unités mais concerne aussi sa mise à
disposition aux officines et donc aux
patients au vu des difficultés
économiques citées précédemment
certaines officines situées dans des
zones plus isolées verrez la fréquence
de leur approvisionnement réduit au
détriment du patient qui a besoin de son
traitement
madame la Présidente voilà les éléments
que la Fédération Française de la
distribution pharmaceutique a souhaité
porter à votre connaissance et je vous
retire bien évidemment mes remerciements
ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de la Commission
de nous avoir permis de nous exprimer
sur ce sujet hautement important
je sais pas si je pense donc monsieur de
Girard
madame la Présidente merci d'avoir
précisé d'emblée la nuance très
importante entre
ce que sont les dépositaires et les
grossistes répartiteurs puisque sont
absolument pas les mêmes métiers dans la
chaîne logistique le dépositaire va être
du côté du laboratoire puisqu'il est
sous-traitant pour ce laboratoire il va
agir pour rendre et pour compte de ce
laboratoire exécuter ses commandes
exécuter ses réceptions ces contrôles
ces stockages et ses préparations de
commande pour un territoire donné
aujourd'hui on assiste à une
complexification de la chaîne de
distribution notamment en amont puisque
tous les produits sont fabriqués
aujourd'hui dans des usines dans le
monde
avec en route cause pour les pénuries ou
une des routes causes essentielles le
manque de capacité de ces usines avec
l'augmentation des demandes en Chine et
en Inde quand bien même ces pays-là
produisent les matières premières donc
manque de matières premières
notamment manque de fabrication de
matières premières en Europe ça c'est un
point manque de capacité de production
du produit finir en Europe
aujourd'hui il y a des efforts de fait
dans ce sens et
différents grands laboratoires
investissent sur leurs usines quand ils
en ont encore sinon auprès de leur
sous-traitants puisqu'il y a deux types
d'approvisionnement certains
laboratoires s'adressent à des
sous-traitants de production ou
produisent eux-mêmes
certains distribués même par le biais de
leur structure dépositaire c'est assez
rare ou externalise chez les
dépositaires
donc on monte un contrat de distribution
pour une zone donnée aujourd'hui
les flux se sont complexifiés on trouve
des plateformes dépositaires européennes
maintenant aujourd'hui
donc implanté en France certaines sont
en France grâce à Dieu et donc ces
plateformes vont distribuer plusieurs
pays européens
ça il faut le savoir mais le laboratoire
gère ses produits en référence et en
numéro de série aujourd'hui ce qui est
imposé par réglementation puisque tous
les produits sont séries réalisés
donc une des choses que l'on préconise
parmi d'autres
c'est de pouvoir faire de la
différenciation retardée sur ce type de
produits à rupture ou à risque et
éventuellement de pouvoir le
différencier pour un pays en
conditionnement secondaire puisque les
dépositaires ont la capacité de faire du
conditionnement secondaire différencier
pour éviter ou essayer de jouer sur les
volumes de produits conditionnés en
matière en conditionnement primaire et
les passer en conditionnement secondaire
pour les différencier pour un pays ça
c'est une des solutions potentielles sur
les ruptures de la part que pour
apporter les dépositaires et au
laboratoire et bien sûr au marché
c'est une des approches
ce que j'ai vécu aussi sur une
plateforme européenne c'est que par
exemple quand un produit avait un ami en
Belgique et nous n'avait pas en France
avec l'aide de la NSM on a pu
transformer le produit avec AMM dans un
autre pays de la Communauté c'était la
Belgique en l'occurrence pour le mettre
en distribution et lever une rupture sur
un produit
d'importance thérapeutique voilà ça
aussi c'est une autre façon de pouvoir
éviter ou de lever une rupture sur un
flux très tendu voilà
donc ça c'est une autre piste aussi
qui est jouable mais elle est modeste
mais ça souffle ça peut sauver des vies
quand même c'était le cas
voilà pour
la position des dépositaires alors dans
l'escarcelle du dépositaire au-delà de
la distribution le dépositaire peut
proposer différents statuts au
laboratoire des statuts d'exploitants
d'importateur d'exportateur le contexte
sport Afrique par exemple si on a des
produits franco-français il peut prendre
à ce moment-là la plateforme peut
prendre en charge des distributions pour
les produits francophones à l'export
donc le dépositaire a plusieurs arcs
plusieurs flèches à son arc et corde à
son arc et donc au vu de tout ça peut
aider
et les laboratoires et les instances
publiques à mieux gérer le dispatching
des stocks
donc ça c'est une de nos approches
aussi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
dépositaires non seulement peuvent
traiter les produits finis prêts à mis
sur le marché ou également
traiter les flux d'API de matière
première pour des pour compte d'un
laboratoire pour certaines de ces usines
c'est ce qu'on appelle
aussi la logistique amont du médicament
API active principalingradiante les murs
en français matières premières à usage
pharmaceutique
voilà donc on voit que le laboratoire
plusieurs rôles à jouer pour aider le
laboratoire
à gérer ses flux amont d'une usine pour
produire les médicaments produits finis
et aussi les recevoir des usines dans le
monde pour les redistribuer vers les
marchés donc les marchés c'est avant
tout les grossistes répartiteurs qui
jouent le rôle avec les accords avec les
laboratoires mais là c'est de l'achat
revente ou des ventes directes aux
hôpitaux pour les grosses commandes
parce que c'est logique qu'un
laboratoire optimiste ces flux et pour
les grosses commandes depuis le
dépositaire va livrer directement aux
hôpitaux parce que c'est justifié
et puis aussi parfois certaines grosses
commandes à certaines officines
quand cela le justifie
logistiquement parlant
voilà un petit peu les fluxamont donc il
faut tenir compte dans ce schéma des
pénuries parce que s'il y a pas de
matière première une fine et il y aura
pas de produit fini
donc pour les pénuries qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait nous pendant le covid donc avec la
santé publique France donc il a été
monté une distribution notamment pour
les produits qui étaient en déficit
c'était les curare et les où est-ce que
j'ai mis ma petite note
les médicaments qui étaient utilisés
dans les services de la réanimation
anesthésie
donc l'écureuil les hypnotiques
notamment donc à partir du 27 avril 2020
donc il y a eu un montage global qui a
été mis en place entre santé publique
France et les dépositaires pour pouvoir
acheminer certaines gammes de produits
d'abord les pour aller stocker en stock
de sécurité et les dispatcher au fil de
l'eau en fonction des besoins sur les
hôpitaux
voilà donc il y a eu un décret et une
instruction des tailles qui détaille ce
schéma contractuel et opérationnel
voilà ce que je pouvais vous préciser
même si j'ai beaucoup de choses à dire
sur le métier de dépositaire qui est
fort intéressant mais connu partout
parce que finalement on est du côté du
laboratoire on est rémunéré en ABC
caustine sont activités donc c'est à
l'unité d'oeuvre quel que soit le
produit on traite des produits à 1500
euros la boîte ou à 10 euros la boîte on
a on est payé à l'activité logistique
donc on grève pas une fine et le coût du
médicament et ça rentre dans le coup
d'exploitation du médicament puisque
nous nos charges c'est le laboratoires
qui nous les qui nous rémunèrent
voilà l'intérêt du dépositaire j'espère
que j'ai pu vous éclairer un peu plus
sur ce métier donc on trouve des
plateformes de 30000 40000 mètres carrés
européen aujourd'hui des positaire
donc ce sont des structures très
importantes et elles sont si importantes
que aujourd'hui avec le ministère de la
Santé le ministère de la Défense il y a
eu le statut de l'OIV qui a été attribué
à certaines plateformes
comportant notamment des certains
produits d'une certaine liste
c'est-à-dire que en cas de
l'extérieur quoi qu'il arrive les
produits entre et sortes de la
plateforme
voilà
tout à fait donc les établissements
dépositaires sont des établissements
pharmaceutiques comme les
établissements des distributions gros
comme les grossistes répartiteurs ou
moi-même je suis pharmacien responsable
de ma structure
en matière responsable en matière
responsable intérimaire en cas d'absence
du pharmacien responsable plus
tout ce qui touche l'assurance qualité
par exemple on parle de d'importation de
médicaments à travers le monde on
colibère les produits pour un marché en
Europe parce que un produit qui vient
d'Angleterre c'est l'export aujourd'hui
on l'introduit et on colibère avec le
laboratoire le produit pour le
si on est point d'entrée en Europe
très bien je vous remercie je vais
passer la parole à notre rapporteur
Laurence Cohen pour une première salle
de question
oui merci messieurs pour pour ces
précisions
concernant les les ruptures à proprement
parler comment le système
Pharma ml qui a été créé en 2003 et
gérer d'ailleurs par les grossistes
répartiteurs
s'articultyle avec le DP rupture et
est-ce que finalement ces systèmes de
d'information permettent aujourd'hui
d'informer suffisamment les acteurs de
la chaîne des ruptures qui sont
constatées par les par les pharmaciens
dans les différentes auditions qu'on a
eu cette
ce problème de d'information est
extrêmement prégnant avec des grandes
inégalités donc j'aimerais vous entendre
sur cette question ma deuxième question
c'est est-ce que vous pensez
les uns et les autres que effectivement
vous avez une part de respons rapidité
et son jugement du tout bien sûr de
valeurs sur ces ruptures
d'approvisionnement par exemple est-ce
que vous procédez à des exportations
parallèles et quelle est l'évolution de
l'exportation dans les activités dans le
chiffre d'affaires des grossistes
répartiteurs et des dépositaires c'est
ma deuxième question ma troisième
question c'est
le fait que l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
interdisent régulièrement l'exportation
de médicaments est-ce que le fait
d'avoir cette disposition valide selon
vous l'existence d'un lien de causalité
entre exportation et pénurie on sait
très bien que les pénuries ont des
causes un multifactorielle donc il n'y a
pas un élément d'explication mais comme
c'est vous qui êtes auditionné peut-être
nous éclaircir sur cette sur cette
donnée
est-ce que vous pensez que les mesures
d'interdiction temporaire de vente
directe par les laboratoires sont
efficaces est-ce qu'elles sont
respectées
mon avant-dernière question consiste
dans l'existence de shortliners qui ne
respecte pas l'ensemble des obligations
d'en parler
à plusieurs reprises qui pèsent sur les
acteurs de la répartition est-ce que ça
vous paraît donc favoriser justement
l'apparition de phénomènes de rupture et
quelle est la part de marché que
représente ces shorts liners qui
disparaissent parfois au bout d'un an
d'activités on l'a pointé nous au niveau
de la y compris de la pas seulement de
la notre commission d'enquête on l'a
déjà pointé au niveau de la commission
des affaires sociales dont nous sommes
dans plusieurs d'entre nous sont membres
et enfin la dernière question que
j'aimerais vous poser les les grossistes
répartiteurs se rémunèrent sur le prix
du médicament faut-il à cet égard
réformé les modalités de fixation des
prix ou bien et où revoir le schéma de
rémunération des grossistes répartiteurs
je vous remercie
très bien je sais pas dans quel ordre on
prend le même ordre pour répondre ou
monsieur puzot oui merci Madame la
rapporteur pour ces quelques questions
alors je vais surtout prendre la
première c'est tel que je l'ai compris
c'est l'articulation du système EDI
Pharma ml avec l'articulation du DP
rupture c'est ça alors moi le pratique
en tous les jours j'ai pas vu de lien
propre entre les deux entre les deux
systèmes informatiques le système
pharmal est un système de communication
entre les officines et surtout les
logiciels de gestion d'officine et nos
systèmes à nous le
déperuptures c'est une plateforme qui
est administrée par l'ordre qui est
renseigné par les exploitants mais il
n'y a pas de lien en fait informatique
ou quoi que ce soit entre les deux et
des fois bon je dirais que c'est même
deux choses pour moi différente sur le
déperuptures on voit effectivement les
différents types de rupture déclarés par
les optimales LGO si je reprends ça le
fin sur le format ml c'est plutôt
l'interrogation de stocks à nous par les
officines qui vont voir si on a le
produit ou pas s'il y en manque
fabricant mon crayon s'il est en rupture
ou s'il ne se fait plus mais pour moi il
y a pas de lien entre les deux
[Musique]
quand vous parlez de la part de
responsabilité sur la les ruptures
d'approvisionnement donc je dirais que
on doit en avoir quelquefois dans la
répartition puisque on n'a pas toujours
demander un approvisionnement au bon
moment donc oui mais comme on est
plusieurs répartiteurs en France si nous
nous avons mal agi à ce niveau-là ou mal
commandé un autre Greta puisque le
pharmacien en général a deux ou trois
répartiteurs va compenser donc c'est pas
une cause de rupture pour moi ce niveau
là
je prends la partie limitée donc les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur par rapport à l'export on n'a pas
si des grossistes répartiteur font de
l'exportation ou de la part ou de
l'exportation parallèle les émitms ne
peuvent pas être exportés si jamais on
le faisait on aurait une amende qui
correspond à un certain pourcentage très
élevé de notre chiffre d'affaires et non
pas sur le médicament question donc il
peut pas il ne peut pas y avoir à mon
avis de lien entre la rupture
l'exportation parallèle et limitée
je peux me permettre de compléter ce
propos là
j'ajouterai aussi que dans le dans le
Code de Santé publique il est dit que
nous ne pouvons faire de l'exportation
que lorsque nos obligations de ces
République sont réalisées
donc il faut attendre déjà qu'on est
fait notre métier par rapport aux
officines qui est notre métier de
répartiteur avant de pouvoir faire de
l'exportation éventuellement
pour les dépositaires concernant le
tracking sur les ruptures nous sommes
absents de tous les systèmes donc trois
semaines c'est exploitant qui qui le
gère des perructures ce sont les
titulaires ou les exploitants et même
très stock ce sont les titulaires ou les
exploitants dans les mêmes
on a aucune connexion et ça faisait
partie de notre proposition
parce que nous on peut voir des signaux
faibles dans nos flux ce qu'on appelle
des signaux faibles précurseurs de
rupture des commandes
extraordinaires sur un produit à un
moment donné sur qui dénote des flux
normaux c'est ce qu'on a on pourrait
appeler des signaux faibles c'est ce que
nous on appelle des myophèles
des retards de livraison sur un produit
parce qu'une usine a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en API en matière
première on a déjà un signal nous on
sent que ça se tend dans nos réceptions
et dans nos flux
voilà donc
une fine et diminuants des diminutions
de niveau de stock dans nos dans nos
états sur nos plateformes donc
nous ce qui nous semble intéressant ça
fait partie de nos propositions c'est si
l'état pouvait monter un nouveau
dispositif dans lequel sera associé les
dépositaires pour essayer de suivre ces
signaux qu'on appelle des signaux
faibles sur les tendances de stock
et qui permettrait aussi d'éclaircir
peut-être avec le laboratoire en amont
ce qui se passe au niveau de leur usines
et plutôt que de subir une rupture
plutôt que essayer de la prévoir et de
décès mythiques de mitiger le risque
avec un autre
flux de médicaments potentiels avec un
autre laboratoire ou ce genre de choses
pour une gamme particulière
donc nous on est absent dans tous ces
tracking
c'est pour moi c'est pas choquant dans
le sens où on travaille pour le
laboratoire c'est le laboratoire qui
gère tout cela en direct dans les
systèmes
maintenant nous avec ces signaux faibles
on peut présenter un certain intérêt
pour prévenir ou sentir les futurs
ruptures qui vont qui se dessine
et peut-être avec quelques routes causes
quelques causes racines
les MITM
ont l'esprit on les suit strictement on
suit strictement la législation
donc au niveau du dépositaire on prendra
aucun risque et le laboratoire encore
moins de mon point de vue
donc
la compliance est très importante dans
le lien qui nous lie au laboratoire
c'est l'image du laboratoire
qu'on peut atteindre par des
dérives qui seraient pas conformes et en
plus dans notre cahiers des charges donc
on est tenu de notre responsabilité est
engagée à ne pas suivre les directives
du laboratoire
donc on exécute
contrairement au cahier des charges
les demandes du laboratoire
et lui le laboratoire doit référer au
travers des systèmes de ces ruptures
il faut bien comprendre comme vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre introduction
que le laboratoire reste propriétaire du
stock et donc le dépositaire agit
d'ordre et pour le compte du laboratoire
donc il y a pas de propriété
interdiction de vente directe au
laboratoire par les laboratoires c'était
quoi cette question vous pouvez la
répéter
est-ce que les mesures est-ce que les
mesures d'interdiction temporaire de
vente directe par les laboratoires sont
efficaces et est-ce qu'elles sont
respectées
la question que j'ai posé
parce que
je citais en fait je faisais référence à
ce qu'il y avait dit le délégué général
de la Chambre syndicale de la
répartition pharmaceutique à propos
notamment de l'amoxicilline donc je
pourrais faire la citation à sujet si
vous voulez c'est pour ça que je vous
posais la question il y a deux autres
questions auxquelles vous n'avez pas
répondu c'est sur les short liners et
aussi sur le fait que
les grossistes répartiteurs se
rémunèrent sur le prix du médicament et
ce que donc il fallait réformer les
choses ou pas c'était les deux questions
on peut pas répondre à leur place je
connais pas cette activité en fait quand
bien même peut-être qu'on en sait ce que
le laboratoire nous demande de servir
tel et tel type de grossiste
l'autre question c'est pour les
grossistes leur système de rémunération
je peux pas m'immiscer dans leur
dans leur stratégie financière
interdiction des ventes des ventes
laboratoire des ventes directes ça c'est
parce que vous avez bien compris il y a
des ventes directes nous nous en faisons
sur des pourcons du laboratoire aux
grosses commandes pharmacies en général
c'est justifié par le flux donc des
grosses commandes c'est légitime de les
livrer directement si la pharmacienne
est capacités de stocker correctement
les médicaments pareil pour les hôpitaux
dans le centre ce qu'on appelle nous les
ventes
je voulais juste
s'il y a un intérêt qu'on peut aussi
dans la vente directe c'est par le biais
des stocks des dépositaires c'est que
vous avez un stock et un stock
centralisé et donc vous n'avez pas de
disons de dilution de différents stocks
au sein de différentes entrepôts vous
avez un stock qui centralisé dans tous
les tous les produits soient au même
endroit ce qui permet de d'avoir accès à
un plus grand volume si on parle de
médicaments qui sont en tension à
rupture et après la question des vents
directs elle est aussi liée à la
stratégie commerciale des
laboratoires aux pharmacies d'officine
puisqu'elle est souvent rappelé Frédéric
de Gérard et les lieux il y a des achats
plus gros volume
donc avec parfois des remises
commerciales oui
je disais que le
fait de faire des ventes par le biais
d'un stock des positaire permet d'avoir
un stock le dépositaire en stock
centralisé donc de faire dans un même
endroit
le stock de médicaments et donc de
pouvoir de ne pas avoir de dilution de
stock dans différents entrepôts qui
seraient répartis sur la France et puis
la question des ventes directes elle
sous-tend aussi la question de la
relation commerciale entre les
laboratoires et les pharmacies
d'officine puisque
comme le rappeler fatigue de Gérard il y
a des plus gros volumes d'achat par les
officines et donc peut-être des remises
commerciales qui pourraient être qui
pourraient entrer en considération dans
le dans cet achat de médicaments par les
pharmacies d'officine ou par les
groupements ou les collectifs de ou les
enseignes de pharmacie
un exemple les produits génériques
historiquement ça avait commencé par des
ventes directes aux femmes aux
pharmacies il y a en 2001 dans les
années 2000 2001 voilà donc les ventes
directes aux pharmacies ont commencé
notamment avec les génériques
la vente directe n'est pas interdite par
aujourd'hui dans les hésitations donc le
laboratoire peut vendre en direct à la
pharmacie
la question qui était posée c'est qu'il
y a eu un blocage réglementaire
transitoire pour faciliter la gestion de
stock et éviter qu'il y ait des flux
parallèles qui créent une inéquité
territoriale de répartition au gré des
relations contractuelles directes entre
un pharmacien et une pharmacienne et une
pharmacie et un laboratoire
oui ce sont des choses qui arrivent
nous on demande quand on demande par
exemple des fois à certains laboratoires
des produits en urgence pour un client
pour un pharmacien le laboratoire nous
dit donnez-moi le nom de la pharmacie et
je vais livrer en direct
ce qui amène une moindre transparence
sur les flux quelque part
moindre transparence sur les flux c'est
à dire que s'il y a des flux parallèles
en dehors de vos actions respectives
sur les médicaments en tension ou en
grande pénurie c'est plus compliqué
quand même de suivre l'état des stocks
et la disponibilité voilà
pour essayer de traquer
les tendances sur les ruptures
Corinne Imbert
merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs
peut-être une précision pour répondre
voilà une réponse de terrain
si ça vous intéresse pas la même
président
oui il y a eu un moment donné des
médicaments allez on va citer le
paracétamol qu'on ne pouvait plus
commander un laboratoire qui est
auditionné il y a pas si longtemps que
ça d'accord pour les raisons que vous
avez évoqué ou alors on pouvait en
commander de façon contingentée
par exemple au lieu de commander trois
cartons parce que vous aviez besoin de
trois cartons et bien il était limité à
un carton par officine par exemple ou
alors un autre toujours un médicament à
base de paracétamol qu'on ne pouvait
plus commander chez les grossistes
répartiteurs ça a duré un temps au
moment où il y avait les plus fortes
tensions pendant pendant l'hiver là les
choses sont revenues un peu à la normale
donc oui à un moment donné les choses
sont imposées
et s'applique parce que de toute façon
le laboratoire à la consigne de cesser
ses livraisons en direct qui n'a pas le
choix vis-à-vis du ministère ce que le
ministère lui demande effectivement pour
pas qu'on ait des stocks qui soient un
peu trop dispersés
vous ayez posé une autre question sur
lequel je la portée des précisions enfin
c'est pas grave je reviendrai dessus
messieurs donc on a bien compris vous
n'avez pas même si vous êtes deux
acteurs de la logistique du médicament
vous n'avez pas les mêmes métiers
exactement moi je voulais vous poser une
question alors qu'on aurait pu poser aux
industriels
j'avoue qu'à l'époque j'ai pas pensé à
leur poser mais je vais vous la poser
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
les industriels et favoriser plutôt les
grossistes répartiteurs à qui ils vont
tout de suite leur médicament ou plutôt
les acteurs dépositaires puisque vous
êtes un logiciel vous travaillez pour le
compte du laboratoire mais quand le
médicament est chez vous il est toujours
propriété du laboratoire il est pas
encore vendu donc est-ce que dans le cas
des pénuries
selon vous
les industriels ont favorisé un circuit
plutôt qu'un autre ou pas voilà la
question est ouverte est-ce que de votre
côté
vous en tant que répartiteur en tant que
dépositaire vous avez appliqué des
contingentements à vos clients
alors vous avez j'ai bien évidemment je
sais bien que
les pharmaciens d'officine ou les
hôpitaux que vous livrez monsieur les
représentants des dépositaires ne sont
pas vos clients mais est-ce que à un
moment donné vous aviez les il y a eu
des consignes de contingentement donné
par le laboratoire ou à l'inverse vous
consisterez par titeur avait appliquer
des contingentements par officine parce
que vous étiez le numéro 2 ou au
contraire vous favorisiez un pharmacien
qui était pour qui vous étiez le premier
fournisseur
et puis côté côté dépositaire quelle
part de marché représente les hôpitaux
par rapport aux officines
ça c'est une question qui vous est plus
particulièrement destinée et également
pour les dépositaires est-ce que vous
vous livrez pour le compte des
laboratoire n'hésite
des MITM parce que peut-être pour les
hôpitaux
pour les officines ça me paraît un peu
plus mais bon vous allez y répondre et
puis je sais
la précision que je voulais vous
apporter sur une question que vous avez
posé mesdames
sur la
je vous donne un exemple un médicament
qui est en rupture qu'on peut pas avoir
ni chez les grossistes dépositaire
encore moins chez short liner qui n'a
pas d'équivalent thérapeutique et bien
effectivement à un moment donné une
pharmacie un peu appelé directement le
laboratoire qui à titre exceptionnel
parce que vous en avez besoin pour
impatient parce que passion n'a plus un
comprimé chez lui le laboratoire va vous
envoyer une boîte de médicaments ça se
fait il y a pas du tout c'est en toute
transparence c'est qu'à un moment donné
il va non pas court-circuiter une chaîne
du médicament mais parce qu'on n'a pas
d'équivalent thérapeutique parce qu'il y
a pas de il y a pas de générique et bien
et parce que votre passion a besoin sans
que ce soit forcément un médicament
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur on a vu
le cas pour pour
un médicament à l'esprit et bien le
laboratoire va vous dépanner de façon
exceptionnelle dans l'intérêt du patient
et l'officine l'officinale recevra la
boîte de médicaments sous 24 à 48 voilà
ça c'est possible mais ça reste
exceptionnel dans la chaîne
d'acheminement puisque les laboratoires
évidemment privilégie la logistique qui
est qui est bien connue avec les
obligations qui s'imposent à chacun je
vous remercie merci beaucoup Bruno tu es
mignonne
juste deux petites questions vous avez
dit répartiteurs dans le propositions
d'amélioration on pourrait imaginer
d'avoir des stocks d'urgence au niveau
régional
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas vous avez parlé vous de grandes
plateformes
les dépositaires donc j'ai pas bien
compris comment ça pouvait être mis en
place aussi ça existait ou pas et la
deuxième question c'est sur
[Musique]
vous a demandé Laurence sur les
exportations parallèles mais apparemment
ni l'un ni l'autre vous le faites donc
d'où sortent les experts les
exportations parallèles dont tout le
monde parle
ce que si vous ne le faites ni les amis
les autres qui qui
fait compléter par une série de
questions et après je vous laisserai
répondre
[Musique]
le reproche est fait sur l'absence de à
plusieurs reprises sur l'absence de
transparence sur sur l'état des stocks
et les laboratoires disent eux-mêmes que
ben non nous on a libéré on a libéré et
c'est dans les stocks
des grossistes répartiteurs et et du
coup je voulais savoir si
un insta de ce qui se fait par exemple
au Pays-Bas
il ne serait pas judicieux qu'il y ait
aussi un état régulier des stocks y
compris chez les grossistes répartiteurs
et aussi dans les plateformes des
distributeurs même si
j'ai compris que le lien était plus
direct avec le laboratoire et que du
coup
le reproche le reproche vous était moins
fait mais c'est vrai que l'état des
stocks dans les plateformes logistiques
quelles qu'elles soient et quand même un
élément important et voilà sur
laboratoire ont évoqué cette question
je vais réagir sur le dispatching santé
publique France
avec les médicaments anesthésiques et
j'aurais aimé d'abord j'aimerais savoir
si c'est reproductible cette situation
avec d'autres médicaments en urgence à
partir du moment on aura une liste des
médicaments critiques est-ce qu'on peut
reproduire
cette organisation en sachant que je ne
sais pas si c'est de votre fête mais les
palettes qui sont arrivées dans les
hôpitaux avec des boîtes
issues de plusieurs pays différents et
des notices en langage différents en
écriture différente des dosages
différents des concentrations
différentes ont quand même provoqué un
risque iatrogène très important alors
c'était des anesthésiques donc là
c'était vraiment il y a eu beaucoup de
boulot après mais est-ce que il y a à
prévoir une amélioration de la procédure
pour qui est pas ce risque et qui est
une espèce d'homogénéité des produits
distribués de façon à ce que quand le
pharmacien reçoit en tout cas dans la
pharmacie hospitalière
on n'est pas ce problème et en tout cas
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
reproductible pour d'autres médicaments
que que les curare en l'occurrence
est-ce que 15 jours c'est suffisant
voilà où est-ce que il faut pas prévoir
plus que 15 jours de
stock pour vous
voilà où au Pays Bas c'est deux mois
également pour voilà pour les grossistes
répartiteurs donc qu'est-ce que est-ce
qu'il faut pas prévoir des stocks ça
c'est un investissement puisque son
c'est de la logistique a et des
zones de stockage à prévoir mais c'est
une question une question qui qui se
pose voilà donc j'essaie question là
complémentaires auprès de vous puisque
l'objectif de la commission d'enquête
c'est d'améliorer
la prise en charge des pénuries et donc
d'être plus efficient encore
en sachant qu'on les anesthésie quand
même il y a eu un arrêté ministériel qui
a été nécessaire donc il y a eu quand
même une procédure exceptionnelle
peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir une
procédure un peu générale qui pourrait
dérouler au moment où une pénurie
délétère apparaîtrait et je crois que
Bruno Belin veut rajouter merci
on a besoin ça c'est essentiel de
l'écrire à un moment donné de
l'entériner dans nos travaux
effectivement d'avoir une lisibilité une
précision sur les stocks et les flux des
stocks
ma remarque fait suite à l'intervention
de Corinne Imbert vis-à-vis des
dépositaires
est-ce que pour le dire correctement
vous n'avez pas le sentiment quand même
d'être responsable mais pas coupable
c'est à dire on va prendre l'exemple
voilà d'un médicament le paracétamol
avec Sanofi qui vous dit on vend en
grosse palette en grosse quantité et
donc aux pharmacies qui ont de la
trésorerie qui ont la possibilité de
stocker et de payer
au détriment des stocks ou du flux de
stock des répartiteurs et notamment ceux
qui vont faire en milieu rural sur des
officines plus petites qu'au moins de
moyens sauf qu'au bout du bout ce sont
effectivement des patients qui sont
lésés il y a une vraie discrimination
employer le terme puisque pour y avoir
des stocks les pharmacies qui auraient
les moyens et ceux qui n'en n'auraient
pas ou de plus faible de plus petites
capacités économiques ou de plus petite
capacité physique n'aurait pas de stock
et n'aurait pas de médicaments
dans la pénurie de médicaments face avec
nous nous sommes toujours confrontés on
va parler au présent et parler du curare
il y a trois ans c'est pas ça le sujet
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est arrivé est-ce que il y
a eu ces choix et ses consignes de
données vous êtes devant une commission
d'enquête parlementaire est-ce que ça
contribuait à créer des carences pour
certains médicaments et donc au
détriment des patients
[Musique]
dans quel ordre
on peut faire le
monsieur plus ouf je vous l'ai répondu
je me permets de répondre aux premières
questions qui ont été posées si vous le
permettez alors sur les favoriser
certains grossistes par rapport à
d'autres alors moi j'ai la chance de
représenter un gros site répartiteur
régional donc je suis pharmacien
responsable dans cet établissement j'ai
pas eu le sentiment là personnellement
dans ma pratique quotidienne et mon
contraire pendant une période d'avoir
moins de produits malgré les demandes
que je faisais les justifications que
j'avais par rapport au laboratoire je
sais pas si ça répond à la question qui
a été posée par rapport à cette
thématique
vous avez bien entendu des questions
est-ce que les grossistes répartiteurs
ont été plus favorisés que les
dépositaires si j'ai bien compris par
rapport à l'approvisionnement aux
médicaments voilà
comme je vous ai dit je représente un
gros site répartiteur je suis formateur
responsable de ce grossiste répartiteur
j'ai pas vu honnêtement eu cette notion
d'être favorisée je dirais même d'avoir
été peut-être un peu même défavorisé
d'avoir moins de produits sur une
période donnée malgré les demandes de
pharmacie
moi je suis mhgc groupe dans le cadre de
ma profession
alors pour le contingentement aussi qui
a été posé et nous avons alors ça c'est
aussi une discussion que nous nous avons
eu avec nos pharmaciens d'officine
justement c'est une grande un grand
débat qu'on a fait pour savoir son
métier des quotas aussi en tant que
grossi sur certains produits dont le
paracétamol notamment le doliprane entre
autres si je reviens là-dessus
quand le quota est tombé le des
laboratoires et que nous on recevait nos
quotas je dirais de produits sur sur ça
on s'est rendu compte que les
pharmaciens d'officine sont des systèmes
edif Pharma-ML nos stocks et prenez tout
donc prenez le carton complet par
exemple et ça veut dire que d'autres
officiers n'ont contrepartie n'avaient
pas de médicaments ça rejoint un peu
aussi ce que ce que vous voilà on a
discriminé alors vous me permettez que
je termine monsieur
donc c'était une question qu'on a
discuté avec certains ce qui nous a été
remonté là c'est ma pratique qui parle
plutôt c'est que le pharmacien préféré
avoir moins de produits à sa commande
moins de doliprane à sa commande mais
plus régulièrement
c'est à dire lui il ne veut plus pas
avoir par exemple un carton en début de
mois qui lui fasse une semaine mais
plutôt que sur la totalité du mois il
puisse avoir 10 20 30 boîtes en fonction
de ce qu'il était pour pouvoir quand
même satisfaire ses patients qui lui
demandaient et pas se retrouver au vin
du mois sans rien il y avait
l'impression d'avoir un flux continu
c'était aussi cette raison pour quand
les amis en place c'est des quotas qu'on
évalue tous les jours avec mon équipe et
aussi avec les pharmaciens avec qui je
travaille on leur pose la question c'est
la proximité qu'on entretient est-ce que
ça répond à la question par rapport à ce
thème là
juste pour compléter ce sont les deux
officines qui nous ont demandé à un
moment donné de mettre en place des
quotas pour eux la question qu'on se
pose c'est que à l'échelle de la France
est-ce qu'il y a un élément de
régulation ce qui a vos officines il y a
les officines des autres il y a les
officines qui qui font en direct des
officines qui passent par les
dépositaires enfin je veux dire à un
moment il faut bien qu'il y ait un
arbitrage quand il y a une situation de
pénurie il faut bien qu'il y ait une
règle une règle du jeu parce qu'en fait
c'est ça le sujet le sujet c'est la
règle du jeu on a un pays qui est fondé
sur l'équité d'accès aux soins en tout
cas on essaie de la maintenir vaille que
vaille et ça la pénurie l'accès aux
médicaments ça participe de l'équité aux
soins du soin alors cette règle du jeu
on l'a essayé de la mettre avec nos
officinaux
il y a pas un pilote dans l'avion
exécutif au niveau national qui veille à
ça
c'est la question ça en fait c'est ça
voilà non non mais je sais pas une
question c'est s'il y a pas la réponse
c'est que ça n'existe pas
merci beaucoup
monsieur de Girard
et son propre dépositaire parce qu'ils
sous-traitent à personne leur logistique
donc là je peux pas parler en tant que
dépositaire pour Sanofi
par contre bien sûr on a d'autres
produits on parlait tout à l'heure des
amoxicillines
oui les laboratoires nous dit que des
contingentements mais équité et c'est
équitable par rapport au marché
voilà donc ça c'est ce que ça signifie
ça signifie quoi par rapport aux
grossiste surtout puisque c'est quand
même le plus gros
en matière de santé publique c'est par
rapport au marché
je me suis mal exprimé au marché
sont les grossistes les pharmacies les
hôpitaux donc le contingentement
essentiellement les gros flux passent
par les grossistes donc c'est pour les
essentiellement pour les grossistes
et puis aussi éviter que
du dispatching par ailleurs de produits
donc vraiment on subit des périodes de
contingentement donc voilà et c'est le
laboratoire qui l'organisme
parce que je peux dire sur le
comptagement donc ça existe
oui on n'est pas vraiment surpris le
comptage lentement par les laboratoires
savions certains ont été faits à la
demande du ministère l'exemple du
paracétamol on est un bel exemple mais
il y a aussi donc il avait dit Monsieur
représentant les grossistes répartiteurs
régionaux il y a eu aussi une volonté
donc de de pas répondre à des commandes
j'allais dire un peu trop importantes
de certains officinaux et justement de
réguler la livraison par rapport à une
forme de contingentement hebdomadaire
mensuel je ne sais pas comment vous
l'avez organisé mais vous l'avez mis en
place c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plusieurs
niveaux de contingentement possible et
si vous dépositaire c'est pas vous qui
décidez du contingentement parce que
vous n'êtes qu'une plateforme de
stockage et les commandes sont adressées
au laboratoire
et vous c'est vous qui faites la
livraison vous vous recevez les
commandes des officinaux si on parle que
de la pharmacie d'officine pour
l'instant et vous avez pu mettre en
place alors on l'appelle contingentement
on l'appel régulation mais à un moment
donné une répartition des livraisons de
médicaments qui étaient sous tension on
est bien d'accord qui est une décision
de vos entreprises mais que je ne
critique pas c'est juste pour pour
éclairer et ça peut se comprendre pour
éviter ce qui évoqué mon voisin
c'est-à-dire des discriminations parce
que tels officiers n'auraient un pouvoir
d'achat plus important que d'autres ou
plus plus rapidement livré que d'autres
et donc des déséquilibrer l'axe aux
médicaments à l'échelle d'équité d'axo
médicaments à l'échelle du territoire
national c'était juste le sens des
questions
juste Monsieur le Représentant des
dépositaires vos parts de livraison
hôpital officine
vous l'avez non peut-être pas
aller dans le micro s'il vous plaît
parce que vous entendez pas nous avons
fait une étude il y a 5 ans pour essayer
de d'objectiver tous ces flux
j'ai plus les chiffres en tête
on parle de 95% des flux grossistes
enfin les dépositaires à destination des
hôpitaux et entre 25 et 30% pour les
flux à destination des officines j'ai
pas compris
j'ai pas fait beaucoup d'études mais je
crois 95% des flux dans le micro s'il
vous plaît 95% des fruits des hôpitaux
non mais vous quand vous recevez sans
boîte vous en envoyez combien à
l'hôpital combien à la pharmacie
l'essentiel des flux de médicaments
passe par les dépositaires et les
grossistes ça c'est l'essentiel des flux
mais de chaque côté vous avez les
hôpitaux qui peuvent être livrant direct
par le laboratoire ou le dépôt de
critères ainsi que les officines voilà
et donc on a essayé de faire des ratios
pour chaque flux après c'est pas les
mêmes médicaments donc tout ça doit
pouvoir voilà donc ça nous intéresse de
de
l'appréhension des flux d'avoir une plus
grande compréhension pour plus de
transparence et et mieux comprendre
parce que qui dit pénurie dit problème
de stock donc des problèmes de
dispatching de des problèmes d'équité
d'accès à certains médicaments et donc
si on n'a pas non plus la une
connaissance un peu plus technique de la
façon dont fonctionne les flux même en
ayant des contingentements ou une
réglementation nationale
on peut pas à s'assurer que l'effet
derrière soit celui de l'équité d'accès
aux médicaments quoi donc on a besoin
d'avoir cet élément là on voit bien que
la chaîne logistique on l'a su pour on
l'a vécu pour les vaccins l'accès au
vaccins pendant la covid la chaîne
logistique c'est à maillon essentiel
essentiel de de l'accès tout autant que
la fabrication parce que si la boîte
arrive et qu'elle est bloquée dans un
entrepôt
de la part de du patient c'est c'est le
même problème il a pas la boîte chez lui
sur la question que vous avez posé
justement sur l'écureur peut-être
qu'effectivement ça date d'il y a trois
ans mais la question est de savoir si un
modèle similaire pour être adapté pour
les médicaments critiques ou en cas de
situation particulière et en
l'occurrence c'était des produits qui
étaient détenus par l'État géré par
santé publique France avec des des
dotations qui étaient remontées au
niveau local en fonction des besoins et
dont la distribution le stockage de la
distribution a été assuré par les
dépositaires
donc c'est un modèle qui a fonctionné
sur les currents et qui pourraient
certainement être dupliqué à d'autres
catégories
quand en réalité quand on vous écoute
ça paraît extrêmement complexe et très
très
compartimenté c'est à dire franchement
au fur et à mesure de l'avancée de cette
audition
je ne suis pas sûr d'y voir plus clair
que à mon entrée c'est peut-être moi qui
suis pas suffisamment attentive mais je
suis très attentive quand même donc
parce que on a vraiment l'impression que
vous êtes dans des compartiments et que
ce que vous ne vous parlez pas c'est un
peu et que justement enfin là il y a eu
entre nos questions les questions de mes
collègues on a essayé de d'essayer de
trouver
le chemin parce que ce qui vous importe
vraiment tous ici et toutes c'est
l'équité devant l'accès aux médicaments
l'égalité quel que soit le territoire
quel que soit la taille de l'officine et
enfin on vous pose des questions un
petit peu différentes les uns et les
autres et en fait ça devient de moins en
moins donc essayez d'être clair concis
ça c'est la première chose et deuxième
point
là il y a une logique purement
mathématique quand on vous demande un
pourcentage entre l'hôpital et les
officines ça peut pas dépasser 100 %.
c'est là c'est voilà c'est élémentaire
mon cher Watson et donc vous n'avez pas
les tableaux et on ne vous en veut pas
mais en fait il faudra nous les fournir
dans le cadre de cette commission
d'enquête pour qu'on voit la proportion
des choses
Bruno Belin et après
j'assiste et j'appuie l'intervention de
la rapporteur que for juste on a besoin
de savoir comment ça s'est produit
comment ça peut se reproduire moi c'est
ce qui m'intéresse demain
l'égalité elle est incontournable mais
comment demain ça ne peut ne pas se
reproduire donc le curare on a compris
vous avez un besoin de 400 000 ampoules
d'un coup parce que personne n'avait
jamais aimé ça et donc ça s'appelle
d'avoir des stocks de sécurité et les
PCH sont faites pour ça mais ça c'est
pas aujourd'hui le quotidien le
quotidien c'est la maman qui vient
chercher son flacon
d'amoxicilline à qui on dit pas parce
que effectivement ce qu'il faut
comprendre Laurence c'est qu'il y a un
vrai volet économique la petite
pharmacie qui demande à être contagie à
recevoir trois par trois et toutes les
dizaines c'est parce qu'elle fait gaffe
à payer sa décade ou à pouvoir payer sa
décade alors que le dépositaire moi je
pensais que c'était coupable mais pas
responsable mais pas coupable à mon mari
on va se demander si on n'est pas chez
tes énardier là c'est à dire que oui oui
il y a que les gros qui peuvent vivre et
puis parce qu'ils vont payer tout de
suite et ça c'est un vrai sujet parce
que ça casse le principe d'égalité à
l'accès de la santé et ça c'est
insupportable pour nous parce que ça
veut dire que si vous êtes avec une
toute petite pharmacie qui a pas de
trésorerie qui a pas les moyens d'avoir
un peu de stock et qui a des difficultés
il peut pas assurer le traitement de son
patient
donc voilà et puis alors effectivement
moi je suis un peu choqué monsieur ZAR
je sais pas quel est votre fonction j'ai
loupé le début pardon mais
que vous ne puissiez pas nous dire que
vous faites 75% et 25% un industrie
enfin 25 % l'officine 75 % les hôpitaux
enfin vous ne connaissiez pas les
chiffres de votre distribution de votre
secteur voilà
monsieur puzot
de santé publique France
les grossistes répartiteurs que que je
représente on participe encore
aujourd'hui au paxo ville dans mes
petites que nos confrères de la CSRP je
pense que le modèle de transparence de
stock avec des stocks d'urgence au
travers d'un tiers de confiance qui peut
être santé publique France sur des
médicaments attention pourrait
s'appliquer on le fait déjà tous les
mois c'est moi qui m'occupe de remonter
les chiffres de mes confrères qui me
remontent leur chiffre du packovide à
qui ils ont vendu Steve leur reste en
stock ce qu'ils ont mis en quarantaine
et j'en passe tout ça c'est toute la
partie logistique et je communique
régulièrement avec santé publique France
pour eux tous dans ça donc je pense
qu'on pourrait et je pense que ceci un
rôle du grossiste c'est pour ça que
notre fédération a souvent appuyée le
fait de mettre des stocks d'urgence
déportés des stocks des exploitants qui
sont déjà je ne sais pas où disséminés
déjà pour réduire le circuit parce que
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
sénateur il faut aujourd'hui quand un
patient demande un médicament il faut
qu'il ait parce que c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas un bonbon un médicament puis
dire si je caricature il en a besoin
cette vital pour lui il y a il y a
vraiment quelque chose pour pour lequel
il y en a besoin donc il faut réduire au
maximum ce circuit et c'est pour ça que
pour moi les grossistes répartiteurs
doivent les avoir pour réduire ce délai
de livraison et que le film est tout de
suite voilà à ce moment-là donc je pense
que cette transparence on peut le faire
on peut déjà dans le cadre de santé
publique France après la définir comment
une plateforme informatique un tiers de
confiance une procédure que vous avez
mentionné à plusieurs reprises dans le
président mais je pense que ça peut être
possible mais par contre sur un nombre
précis de médicaments dit en tension
on peut pas le faire sur 6000 ou 20000
références voilà c'était l'objet de ma
question c'est à dire que en fait c'est
sur une liste limitative qui est en
cours de constitution de médicaments dit
critiques et à risque finalement d'être
en pénurie plus rapidement que les
autres y compris liés à la chaîne de
fabrication de pouvoir avoir une
procédure un peu reproductive pour
compléter alors effectivement le
paxovite un stop d'État je pense que
c'est aussi la notion de stock d'État
qui doit être les étendue sur ces
médicaments dit en tension et pas
uniquement à ceux que l'on fait
aujourd'hui à ce moment-là par contre ça
implique pour moi aussi que dans ce
cas-là sinon on joue en jeu avec les
laboratoires eux le font le fasse aussi
c'est à dire que sur des besoins de
produits importants justifiés les
laboratoires nous permet de nous
approvisionner en conséquence je dirais
de manière appropriée et continue dans
ce sens
effectivement il y a pas de
d'anticipation alors parce que ou alors
il faudrait imposer ce stock de sécurité
sans des convaincu l'Académie nationale
de pharmacie va travailler sur une liste
de 100 médicaments pour donner un ordre
de grandeur sur les 6 ou 7000
spécialités que vous évoquez mais il y a
aussi d'anticipation
pourquoi on manque de vogalen New York
aujourd'hui
excusez-moi c'est un truc qui est
aussi vieux que la Cinquième République
une forme galénique qu'on connaît depuis
pareil une centaine d'années pourquoi on
n'a pas de Logan aujourd'hui
on sort d'une période hivernale
un truc à 2 euros 18 un truc
c'est tout à fait ça
alors je pense aussi que là nous on
pourra pas répondre parce que nous comme
je vous l'ai dit on ne produit pas donc
on reçoit le produit du laboratoire
ils me disent on en a pas par contre je
sais que quand mes confrères office nous
les appellent des fois ils en ont un peu
donc on est vraiment pas il y a pas
égalitaire ceci donc ça veut dire que le
la chaîne du flux du médicament a besoin
d'être regardé avec attention pour au
moins la comprendre et pouvoir réagir
voilà en situation d'urgence et de
pénurie critique quoi
ce qui n'est pas simple ce qui n'est pas
simple
Corinne juste une remarque pour un nid
de notre un peu positive dans ce dans ce
débat puisque vous évoquez la chaîne il
n'y a pas que du négatif on arrive sur
des oui alors positif pas forcément sur
la question des ruptures et des ruptures
d'approvisionnement juste sur la chaîne
du médicament que vous évoquez
il y a quand même
une sécurité de l'approvisionnement non
pas en nombre puisque sinon parait pas
de pénurie il y aurait pas cette
commission d'enquête mais sur la qualité
du médicament distribué et acheminées de
l'industriel à l'officine ou de
l'industriel à l'hôpital et ça faut
quand même le rappeler le trafic de faux
médicaments au niveau international je
pense que c'est plus important que le
trafic de droit selon certaines études
qui ont été faites aujourd'hui il y a ce
qu'on appelle la sérialisation c'est à
dire un petit carré sur les boîtes qui
donnent une traçabilité de chaque boîte
de médicaments
qui est faite et et voilà si il y a des
choses d'améliorer on le voit bien en
période de pénurie évidemment mais
néanmoins
nous avons les cette sécurité de la
chaîne du médicament ça traçabilité la
responsabilité des pharmaciens qui sont
engagés que ça soit chez grossiste
répartiteur on l'a vu chez les
dépositaire qui est important dans notre
pays et qui fait que en France jusqu'à
présent
on n'était pas confrontés à ce trafic de
faux médicaments ce qui n'est pas le cas
partout dans le monde voilà je voulais
amener cette petite note positive dans
ce débat un peu tendu cet après-midi et
puis je voilà
on essaie de comprendre et donc vous
dans les solutions que vous aviez
évoquées il y a les les AMM qui
pourraient être ajustées pour pouvoir
gérer des stocks d'un pays à l'autre
ça et c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
passé pour les boutures
la question des conditionnements
multilingues que vous évoquez aussi et
aussi une piste
une
qu'on voit dans certains pays et il
faudra qu'on l'écrive un
QR code il faut qu'on retire les
boîtages parce que ça ne sert à rien
d'avoir tout flaconnage ou tout et on
met on retire les notices
on va économiser du papier ça va être
aussi bon ça
on a besoin de ça exactement
et on met et on met tout le monde a un
téléphone et peut lire un QR code c'est
déjà le cas dans certains pays
comme il y a des zones blanches et que
tout le monde n'est pas agile avec ses
engins là ces outils là l'idée c'est de
pouvoir quand même s'adosser sur un
réseau de pharmacien pour pouvoir
distribuer à la demande une notice
papier
mais c'est une réflexion au niveau
européen aussi qui est nécessaire parce
que on voit bien dans vos propos que la
gestion des stocks au niveau européen
est aussi un élément important puisque
les flux voilà l'arbitre d'un pays à
l'autre dans le distribution des
laboratoires on le voit bien et que les
effets
de frontières notamment en raison du
prix du médicament sont bien connus des
patients qui vont se fournir de l'autre
côté de la frontière donc voilà
très bien je sais pas si vous voulez
vous donner un élément complémentaire
et la gestion des imités mais cette fois
destination des hôpitaux donc
effectivement
de nombreux dépositaires mettent en
place des permanences nuites et jours le
week-end et jours férié pour pouvoir
servir des produits lifeaving comme on
dit pour les hôpitaux voilà donc ça
c'est quand même des actions qui sont
mises en place
l'export parallèle personne n'en a parlé
mais bon c'est plutôt dans le domaine
ouais mais c'était dans la question qui
c'était dans la question qui
donc ça
bon
c'est certain que d'avoir une vision
globale des stocks par exemple en France
oui ce serait ce serait une approche
exhaustive de mon point de vue ça c'est
sûr en tout cas ça me manque
c'est un chez nous qui manque
une vision globale des stocks et des
flux la reproductibilité de ce qui a été
construit avec santé publique française
effectivement ça pourrait être une
nouvelle procédure à simplifier pour
certains cas particuliers
d'urgence t de pandémie notamment ou
d'autres types d'urgence
est-ce que c'est salvateur par rapport
aux pieux ça c'est un autre débat encore
ça réglera pas le le structurel mais
sera au moins un impact sur le
conjoncturel ça permet de réagir à la
situation d'urgence
très bien
merci merci beaucoup donc on va vous
faire parvenir à un questionnaire à
compléter avec un certain nombre de
sujets particuliers merci de cet échange
qui c'est une commission d'enquête donc
c'est
ça un peu vif une commission d'enquête
mais en même temps on rebondit et on
essaie d'avoir des éléments précis
l'objectif quand même à l'issue c'est
d'avoir des des propositions
suffisamment efficiente et efficaces
pour régler une partie de la des
problématiques on va parler
industrielles réindustrialisée en un an
mais en revanche on peut régler la
question des pénuries qui traînent
depuis une quinzaine d'années qui vont
croissants qui s'aggravent et qui
prennent un tour particulièrement
dangereux du point de vue de la santé
publique
je vous remercie beaucoup merci